[Musique]
un nouveau servi de contestation en
france mobilisation des gilets jaunes
des opposants pas sanitaire la
dénonciation de la hausse des prix de
l'énergie s'est elle aussi invitée dans
les cortèges des rassemblements étaient
organisés un peu partout
matteo salvini devant la justice le
procès du dirigeant italien d'extrême
droite s'est ouvert à palerme alors
ministre de l'intérieur il reprochait
d'avoir bloqué illégalement en mer ton
47 migrants en 2019 leur refusant de
débarquer la prochaine audience a été
fixée au 17 décembre
matteo salvini risque jusqu'à
présents
et
délégation du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu est en mission au sahel ce week
end avant niger première étape au mali
après deux coups d'état militaires en
neuf mois les nations unies veulent
pousser bamako à revenir à un pouvoir
civil
[Musique]
et
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france
contre la réforme des retraites et du
chômage contre la hausse de la précarité
et la baisse du pouvoir d'achat les
gilet jaune ont donné de la voix ce
samedi ils se sont mobilisés notamment à
paris le compte rendu des laines
masquelier
le retour des gis les jaunes et bien
actée ce samedi encore ils étaient
plusieurs centaines à défiler dans les
rues de paris un nouveau souffle porté
par la protestation contre la hausse des
prix du carburant un combat qu'il mène
depuis 2019 et qui avait été à la base
de leur mouvement dans la capitale
un défilé dans le calme mais une colère
toujours bien présente
qu'ils arrêtent de nous taxer qu'ils
arrêtent de se gaver sur des produits de
première nécessité indispensable pour
l'ensemble des français on ouvre à
qu'étant en nous prenons toujours notre
argent et en se demandant derrière
comment on pourrait faire pour leur
permettre de diminuer un petit peu leur
charge en leur reversant notre argent
alors c'est un comble
après une chute des prix de l'énergie en
2020 ces tarifs connaissent un fort
rebond depuis l'été pour étouffer la
colère qui couve le gouvernement a
annoncé le versement d'une indemnité
inflation fixé à 100 euros pour les
français gagnant moins de 2000 euros
nets mensuels une somme jugée dérisoire
par de nombreux protestataires
le chèque de 100 euros c'est juste pour
endormir les gens parce que si vous
divisez 100 euros par part 12 mois ça
fait quoi 8 euros au bout de votre plein
donc c'est pas c'est pas suffisant 100
euros vous retirez les taxes ça veut
dire qu'on à 39 euros sur une année pas
décomptés par jour ce que ça fait c'est
des miettes et puis toute façon faut
arrêter de se [ __ ] de notre gueule
c'est pas les 100 euros qui vont changer
quoi que ce soit dans la vie des gens ce
chèque c'est une énorme connerie c'est
une escroquerie c'est un truc politique
s'est il est encore pagny électorale
sans le dire voilà on va tout faire pour
l'empêcher de gagner ça c'est le but là
le prochain projet notre projet à nous
puisque l'huile à des projets c'est de
l'empêcher de gagner la prochaine
élection une colère populaire que
redoute le gouvernement à l' approche
des élections présidentielles le retour
des gis les jaunes et surveiller comme
le lait sur le feu par l'exécutif avec
la crainte que le mouvement reprenne la
même ampleur qu il y a trois ans
alléger les jaunes qui fêteront dans
quelques semaines le troisième
anniversaire du mouvement mouvement né
en réaction à la hausse des carburants
alors que les prix d'énergie atteignent
aujourd'hui des sommets il appelle à la
reprise des ronds points illustration
dans le rhône où ils sont plusieurs à se
retrouver chaque jour pour faire
entendre leurs revendications
reportage luis carballo et adrien
fontonne où
ils se réunissent chaque jour à 16h pour
dénoncer encore et toujours aux abords
de ce rond-point villeurbanne lés gilet
jaune se mêle désormais aux antilles
passe et autres salariés suspendue car
non vaccinés avec un message inchangé ou
presque j'étais déjà sur le rond-point
en 2018
et avec les mêmes revendications à dire
mais en plus grave beaucoup plus grave
aujourd'hui parce que
ça continue en fait ça s'arrête jamais
quoi j'aurais même politique et
donc on est là en 2018 et on sera encore
là tout les manif du samedi je trouve
qu'elles ne servent pas à grand chose au
niveau politique si on n'est pas bien
écouté et que là on peut on veut
vraiment se retrouver avec la population
expliquer pourquoi on est encore là et
toutes les dérives
gouvernement est en train de faire
depuis deux trois quatre ans là depuis
et qui est l'accentuent depuis la crise
sanitaire au départ économiques et
sociaux les enjeux sont devenus
sociétaux pour de nombreux français car
si la question du pouvoir d'achat avec
la nouvelle hausse des prix du carburant
est toujours centrale pour beaucoup la
crise sanitaire a entamé une fracture
toujours plus profonde avec le
gouvernement tout à augmenter les
salaires ne suivent pas on est dans la
précarité il ya des gens qui sont en
souffrance psychologique économique et
qu'il est là on va droit au mur on est
bafouée de partout le gouvernement nous
nous supprime nos droits ont droit de la
liberté dans un premier temps qui est
pour moi compris qu est plus important
que même l'argent ya des soignants qui
se retrouvent sans emploi qui n'ont
d'autre choix que de se faire vacciner
donc pour moi c'est une obligation donc
à partir de là du moment que c'est une
obligation les droits n'hésiteront plus
à l'instar de djamila des milliers de
manifestants espèrent bien se faire
entendre à travers le pays et ne perdent
pas espoir bientôt trois ans après le
lancement du mouvement des gilet jaune
et les mesures du gouvernement arrêts
quand est l'indemnité inflation de son
euro fera destination de ceux qui
gagnent moins de 2000 euros net par mois
ne convainquent pas en tout cas pas
jacquemod membre à des gels et jaune et
patrick beaulieu bas-congo doctorat en
droit à l'université à paris c'est
clichy l'été sur notre plateau cet après
midi qu'il faut pas se laisser berner
par par les mesures de ce gouvernement
c'est une arnaque tout comme l'a été le
grand débat ou encore plus récemment la
convention citoyenne le gouvernement est
malin il voit que la colère gronde dans
les foyers du coup comme à son habitude
à y donne des miettes pour endiguer un
potentiel mouvement de contestation qui
que ce soit les gilet jaune ou haute
mais ce que veulent la majorité des
français c'est pouvoir vivre dignement
et subvenir aux besoins de leur famille
si le gouvernement croit qu'un ridicule
chèque de 100 euros va atténuer les
colère des français je pense qu'il fait
il fait gravement fausse route donc dès
lors on a du mal maintenant vous avez vu
avec edouard philippe on avait il avait
tout de suite renoncer à certaines taxes
mais le gouvernement castex a du mal à
renoncer au texte parce que renoncer à
cette taxe elle s'est privé des moyens
de relance économique justement dans ce
salon propose un chèque que tout le
monde comprend que ça ne va pas résoudre
les problèmes puisqu'il y aura des taxes
après les villas des dents ça devient
comment je peux dire un serpent de mer
la solution à ce problème ne veut pas
être retrouvé avant la période
électorale c'est hélas au prochain
gouvernement pour la prochaine mandature
de résoudre justement les problèmes
posés par les mouvements des gilets
jaunes actuellement et en parallèle des
gilet jaune mobilisation contre le pass
sanitaires pour le 15e samedi consécutif
à l'appel de florian philippot président
du parti des patriotes
rassemblement place du palais royal dans
la première arrondissement de la
capitale le cortège a pris la direction
du quartier de l'école militaire un
défilé pour la liberté selon la
rhétorique
de chris amon et notamment arrive dans
les cortèges et ça c'était prévisible et
tout de suite en arrivant de quelqu'un
me l'a dit quelqu'un qui n'a jamais
manifesté des jo qui sont vaccinés qui
ont cru que c'était fini le 15 novembre
qui ont cru qu'il serait débarrassé
tranquille est libre et ils viennent de
réaliser que ça n'était que le début du
cauchemar les pilot rejoignent héros de
l égard de l extrême droite qui mobilise
contre elle une manifestation était
organisée à lyon dans une tribune
publiée sur mediapart de nombreuses
personnalités de gauche d'extrême gauche
et écologistes appelés à protester
contre les violences de l'extrême droite
en 6 de jean luc mélenchon l'écologiste
sandrine rousseau ou encore l'activiste
tawaf appel entendu par 5000 personnes
selon les organisateurs 1800 selon la
préfecture notre reporter guimard aussi
étaient sur place ce sont plus d'un
millier de personnes qui ont battu le
pavé ce samedi à lyon dans le cortège de
nombreux mouvements partis politiques
également syndicats la cgt par exemple
mais également sud solidaires la france
insoumise à l'origine de cette
manifestation mais aussi le npa de
nombreux militants anti-fascistes est
certes un gilet jaune bref tout ce que
la gauche antiraciste peut compter de
nuances alors dans ce cortège on a pu
entendre de nombreux slogans anti
fasciste car c'était bien ce qui était
dénoncé ce samedi à lyon la présence de
l'extrême droite de l'ultra droite dans
la capitale des gaules et plus
généralement la montée de cette mouvance
dans l'hexagone et coûté c'est nude très
compliqué sur lyon en fait les violences
de l'extrême droite ça date de
des années ça n'a pas été réglé honni au
niveau médiatique au niveau politique
malheureusement c'est pas seulement à
lyon c'est à dire on lui rend il ya
peut-être des des histoires liées à la
cahc la création de génération
identitaire mais ce qu'on observe c'est
que d'un côté il ya d'extrême droite
isation du paysage politico-médiatique
ya pas que zemmour malheureusement il
n'y a plus d'eau plus de gens qui suce a
aidé autre côté c'est classique vous
avez des groupuscules ultra violents qui
sont là pour intimider et m imposer leur
ans dans la rue voilà et ben il faut
lutter contre les deux faut lutter à la
fois contre la propagande raciste et
fasciste à la télé par des gens qui ont
pignon sur rue et dire montrer à ces
groupuscules qu on les craint pas qu'on
ait la main de manière massive pacifique
unitaire je crois que c'est c'est le b à
ba est le minimum déjà qu'on puisse
faire à lyon il faut savoir que nous
savons quand même une terre fertile par
rapport au mal à monter des violences de
l'extrême droite et donc nous sommes là
pour dénoncer tout cela est pur voilà se
montrer dans la rue pour dire stop
également alerté tous les la préfecture
entre autres puisque les locaux de
l'extrême droite notamment immensité de
générations qui se sont ouverts il n'ya
pas longtemps alors que nous nous avons
demandé la fermeture de ses locaux nous
avons quand même relativement nombreuses
et nombreux pour dire stop et arrêter de
cette montée d'extrême droite de façon à
ce que voilà
impossible alors certains esprits
étaient très échauffés et le dispositif
policier lui très conséquents car on a
craint tout l'après midi des
affrontements entre des militants anti
fascistes et des membres de l'ultra
droite il faut dire que le cortège
passait dans le vieux-lyon décrit comme
le fief de l'extrême droite dans la
capitale des gaules alors les deux camps
se sont fait face à plusieurs reprises
mais toujours séparés l'un de l'autre
par une centaine de mètres et par
plusieurs cordons de policiers pas
d'heures donc heureusement a déclaré une
manifestation anti ultra droite
lyonnaise qui s'est donc déroulée sans
accroc c'est samedi et on reste en
france avec cette situation cocasse pour
certains compliqué pour les principaux
intéressés depuis l'entrée en vigueur de
la nouvelle carte d'identité au format
carte bancaire certains noms de communes
trop longs sont automatiquement aux
raccourcis et ce sont donc parfois des
informations incomplètes qui figurent
sur ce document officiel reportage on au
parquet à grégoire 10 s
camille n'en revient pas celui qui est
resté maire de la commune de saint
quentin la motte lacroix au bailli
pendant près de trois décennies est un
peu choqué par sa dernière mésaventure
il voulait obtenir une procuration pour
son fils mais pour cela il lui fallait
une carte d'identité en cours de
validité
il a réclamé son renouvellement avant
d'apprendre que la longueur du nom de sa
commune posait problème je voulais pour
mon deuxième fils une occurrence ion et
puis je téléphone à la mairie de 50 ha
pour moi je connais bien forcément il
quinzaine de jours après que deux
téléphones anodine schéma comme excuse
mais 50 à la map la croisons moyenne ne
passe pas sur les cartes d'identité vous
savez on ne se rend pas on prend pas
contact qu'une carte d'identité surtout
maintenant sont performantes mais c'est
indispensable
et ça vous bloque beaucoup de choses ne
voulait pas et camille n'est pas le seul
à connaître ce type de péripéties dans
le village un des habitants de notre
commune s'est d'abord adressé à nous
pour obtenir une carte dit noter qu'il
ne possédait pas et nous ne sommes pas
centre notre commune n'est pas centre de
traitement des dossiers de demande de
carte d'identité il faut s'adresser à la
commune d'à côté qui s'appelle eu un des
plus petits noms français ont eu
seulement de te caractère il n'avait
toujours pas de nouvelles il est donc
retourné voir les services et on lui a
appris à ce moment là qu'ils ne
pouvaient bénéficier d'une carte
d'identité au nouveau format parce que
le nom de notre commune comporte trop de
caractère 38 caractère ce nom qui existe
depuis l'an 800 regroupe trois lieux
dits le raccourcir serait un réel crève
coeur pour les habitants en france plus
de 40 communes sont confrontées à cette
amputation administrative
c'est un procès très attendu qui s'est
ouvert ce matin à palerme en italie
celui du dirigeant italien d'extrême
droite matteo salvini l'ancien ministre
de l'intérieur doit répondre
d'accusation de séquestration notamment
les faits remontent au mois d'août 2010
9 il avait alors interdit le
débarquement de 147 migrants secourues
en mer par une ong la première audience
procédurale a duré trois heures la
prochaine a été fixée à la mi décembre
sébastien chabal et sérielle bois
salvini n'aura pas eu le temps de rendre
des comptes aujourd'hui il se sera
contenté d'une figuration au tribunal de
palerme où il comparaissait pour avoir
interdit à un navire humanitaire
d'accoster sur les côtes italiennes
lorsqu'il était ministre de l'intérieur
en 2019 une déception certaine pour les
plaignants dont le fondateur de l'omg
open arms qui s'était exprimé sur ses
attentes assurant que le procès n'a pas
de motivation politique
de son côté matteo salvini martèle le
contraire
de ce procès nous attendons la justice
c'est la première fois qu'une ong
utilisent la voie judiciaire d'abord
pour annuler le décret de sécurité pour
pouvoir entrer dans les eaux
territoriales et pour pouvoir débarquer
les mineurs avec le tribunal des mineurs
de palerme et pour pouvoir entrer dans
le port avec le procureur d'agrigente et
concernant les souffrances inutiles que
toutes ces personnes ont subi pendant
ces quinze jours nous espérons que
justice sera faite
je suis désolé pour deux raisons pour le
temps que je ne passe pas avec mes
enfants et pour l'argent que les
italiens dépenses pour ce procès
politique organisée par la gauche
défendre les frontières c'est un devoir
pas seulement pour un ministre mais pour
chacun et il est souligné dans notre
constitution je pense qu'être accusé
parce que j'ai fait mon devoir est
absurde en août 2019 le navire espagnol
open arms se retrouvent bloqués à
quelques centaines de mètres du port
italien de lampedusa à son bord cent
quarante sept migrants le navire sera
retenu en mer 19 jours avant d'être
accueilli à lampedusa peu après une
enquête pour séquestration de personne
et ouverte matteo salvini qui souhaite
consolider sa position au sein du
gouvernement appelle à tenir des
élections anticipées abandonné par ses
alliés du mouvement 5 étoiles il décide
de quitter le gouvernement après un
premier report de son procès matteo
salvini s'était exprimé plus tôt cette
année pour se défendre des accusations
portées à son encontre
la défense de la patrie et le devoir
sacré de tout citoyen je vais être jugé
pour cela pour avoir défendu mon pays je
me rendrai la tête haute
l'ex ministre de l'intérieur avait déjà
été accusé dans une affaire similaire
concernant un autre navire la justice
italienne a abandonné les poursuites en
mai dernier lors de ce nouveau procès et
matteo salvini encourent jusqu'à 15 ans
de prison
un procès qui permettra de faire la
lumière sur les actions menées par les
différents membres du gouvernement
italien concernant la question
migratoire c'est la vie que fabien gilot
front saignant l'université de turin ce
procédé très intéressant non pas
seulement par rapport à matteo salvini
mais par tout le système d'accueil qu'il
peut y avoir des migrants matteo salvini
a défendu une ligne qu'il a tenu
jusqu'au bout ce sera justement
intéressant durant ce procès de comparer
certains autres membres du gouvernement
à ce moment là les deux autres ministres
qui avait signé avec matteo salvini au
début avant finalement de rebrousser
chemin
l'ancien président du conseil monsieur
compte et qui appeler la témoigner mais
également par exemple le l'ambassadeur
italien à l'union européenne qui lui
aussi va témoigner aujourd'hui et parler
des difficultés qu'il a pu avoir
également avec bruxelles pour replacer
ensuite ces migrants c'est tout le
système aujourd'hui c'est pas seulement
matteo salvini qui va passer sous le
procès c'est tout le système
d'intégration et d'arrivée des migrants
il va y aura pas aujourd'hui ce procès
une délégation du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu est en mission au sahel ce
week-end première étape le mali avec
l'objectif de pousser bamako à revenir
un pouvoir civil après deux coups d'état
militaires en neuf mois établir aussi un
calendrier électoral a prôné cette
visite nous avons posé la question à des
crimes à yaacoub koudougou me chercheur
associé au groupe afrique de l'est pse
vu la situation actuelle le gouvernement
malien estime que la priorité absolue à
l'urgence se fractionner pas
l'organisation des élections dans des
conditions actuelles de la situation
sécuritaire et politique du mali je ne
vois pas comment aujourd'hui le mali
soit capable d'organiser en deux mois
parce que deux mois une élection
présidentielle alors que beaucoup
beaucoup de contraintes sécuritaires et
politiques
la non application de l'accord d'alger
la stabilité politique du pays font
qu'aujourd'hui il est pratiquement
impossible même si la pression est forte
du côté de la cedeao ou de l'onu sur le
gouvernement
les ambassadeurs mobiliser en faveur
d'haussmann kavala seront déclarés
persona non grata en turquie
déclarations du président turc après que
les ambassadeurs de dix pays dont la
france l'allemagne et les etats-unis ont
lancé un appel en faveur de la
libération de l'opposant
recep tayyip erdogan ordonne leur
expulsion figure majeure de la société
civile haussmann kavala est accusé
depuis 2013 par le pouvoir de chercher à
déstabiliser la turquie il est notamment
reproché à l'homme d'affaires d'avoir
soutenu en 2013 les manifestations
antigouvernementales il est emprisonné
depuis et 2017 dont l' attente de son
jugement
c'est là soit les 10 ambassadeurs
connaissent la turquie la comprennent
le jour où ils ne connaissent ou ne
comprennent plus la turquie ils devront
partir d'ici
direction la pologne où des mères de
famille se mobilise en soutien aux
migrants coincés à la frontière avec la
biélorussie un rassemblement était
organisé dans la ville frontalière de
michèle o o ces femmes sollicitent une
aide humanitaire à destination des
réfugiés qui tentent depuis des semaines
de rejoindre l'union européenne varsovie
rocheuses de les accueillir l'état
d'urgence a été déclaré dans la zone des
soldats déployés et les autorités
envisagent de construire un mur
bruxelles de son côté accuse minsk
d'orchestrés cet afflux en représailles
aux sanctions imposées par lieu parmi
les manifestantes aujourd'hui de
l'ancienne première dame elle appelle la
pologne à venir en aide aux enfants
me dédier de la place de l'enfant et
dans un foyer chaleureux dans les bras
de sa mère nous sommes assis dans nos
maisons chaude nous regardons les
nouvelles et nous nous disons c'est
dommage que tant de mal se produisent
chacun d'entre nous a une réelle
possibilité d'aider dans ce domaine
ne sommes surtout pas d'accord avec le
traitement inhumain des enfants nous
n'acceptons pas que nous femme et mère
polonaise soyons les observatrices du
drame qui se déroule sous nos yeux
est la russie confrontée à une violente
vague épidémique les records de 17
contamination liée aux qu'ovide se
multiplient vladimir poutine a ordonné
une semaine chômé la mairie moscou
fermera pour en ce jour toutes les
entreprises et commerces non essentiels
à compter de jeudi prochain la
correspondance de 20 à goffman
1515 décès plus de 37000 cas de
coronavirus nouveaux records aujourd'hui
en russie du nombre de décès et de
contaminations liées aux qu'ovide moscou
le principal foyer épidémique en russie
enregistre aujourd'hui près de 8000
nouveaux malades du coronavirus je
rappelle que selon le décret signé par
vladimir poutine et les prévu
d'instaurer une période chômée dans
toute la russie du 30 octobre au 7
novembre
moscou cette période commence plus tôt
le 28 octobre les restaurants les salles
de sport les centres commerciaux les
salons de beauté ou encore les cinémas
doit être fermé pour ce qui est des
magasins d'alimentation et des
pharmaciens ils continueront à
fonctionner à l'issue de cette période
les autorités prévoient d'introduire
lusage du coup art code pour aller au
théâtre et au musée pour longtemps je
vous propose d'écouter
il faut comprendre que l'écart gones
sont introduits pour que les gens
s'habituent progressivement au fait
qu'il est indispensable se faire
vacciner
cette période de mise en place d'une
situation où de plus en plus de
personnes doivent se faire vacciner peut
prendre des mois pas des semaines
il faudra plus d'un mois pour effectuer
le cycle complet de vaccination les
jours chômés remettent une rupture
immédiate beauchesne de contamination
ne
s'agit de mesures d'urgence à laquelle
on a recours mais lorsque le pandémie a
atteint son pic et qu'elle devait agir
immédiatement
à savoir aujourd'hui mais le pic de la
maladie réduire son incidence
est bien sûr aucun qr code nora un tel
effet
la flambée des chiffres décontamination
des dessins aussi est due à la
propagation du variante delta ii
coronavirus jugé plus agressifs et plus
mortelles ainsi qu'aux taux de
vaccination encore assez faible à peine
48 millions de personnes ont bénéficié
d'une vaccination complète sur une
population de plus de 144 millions
d'habitants
retour en france ou sur la nouvelle
doctrine de lutte informatique dans
fluence le ministère des armées l'a
présenté ce mercredi le document dont le
qui dans le cadre des opérations
extérieures il sera notamment possible
de diffuser des contenus fut dans
l'espace médiatique pouvant induire en
erreur l'adversaire le point l'enquêté
technique
la france va muscler sa cyber défense
qui va prendre un tour plus percutant la
loi de programmation militaire 2019 2025
on avait fait une priorité
le cadre manqué de souplesse pour entrer
par la grande porte dans la guerre
informationnelle alors la ministre des
armées florence parly vient de présenter
la doctrine militaire de lutte
informatique d' influence nommé l21 elle
propose un cadre pour contrer les
menaces exponentielle dans l'ère des
médias sociaux on écoute florence parly
la lutte informatique d' influence
cela désigne l'ensemble des opérations
militaires
conduites en appui de nos forces dans le
champ informationnel pour détecter
caractérisée contre et des attaques ou
appuyer la communication stratégiques
associées à une opération alors que
contient cette aile 21 elle détaille les
moyens pour se défendre dans le
cyberespace contre le terrorisme ou la
manipulation d'état à visées hostiles
contrer les attaques informationnelles
adverse s'opposant à l'action de nos
forces pour les faire cesser ou en
atténuer les effets dénoncer les
incohérences ou mensonge de l'adversaire
promouvoir l'action des forces armées
sur les médias sociaux mais comment
faire jeu égal avec les autres
puissances qui selon florence parly ne
rechigne pas se servir de l'information
fausse manipulée ou subvertit comme
d'une arme la france va se doter de
nouveaux réflexes tout du moins
officiellement dénoncée contenir
affaiblir ou discrédités y compris par
la ruse une attaques informationnelles
un dur adversaire en erreur ou encore
approuvé les opérations menées dans le
champ physique par des manoeuvres de
déception c'est à dire de dissimulation
ou de tromperie utiliser légalement la
ruse le mensonge sur internet même pour
contenir une attaque est tout de même
une vraie rupture épistémologique pour
la france un saut en avant qui avait
déjà été franchie avec pertes et fracas
en 2020 facebook avait détecté des
comportements inappropriés coordonnées
sur son réseau concernant des
communautés en république centrafricaine
et au mali faux profils aux photos
volées même vidéo insultante certains
provenaient d'individus russes liés à
une société de mercenaires d'autres
d'individus français au coude à coude
pour vanter leur influence positive dans
la région les deux groupes rivaux ont
fini par s'affronter directement dans
des espaces de discussion s'accusant
mutuellement de engager des frais que
nous la france jouant les facs shaker en
décembre le rapport grafika et
l'internet observatory de standford ont
épinglé cet état de fait en créant des
faux comptes et des fausses pas gentil
fightnews pour combattre les trolls elle
les intervenants français ont perpétué
et implicitement justifié le
comportement problématique qu'ils
entendaient combattre de guerre lasse
les français vont officiellement utilisé
des armes déloyales pour disposer des
mêmes que tout le monde sinon c'est pas
du jeu et aujourd'hui l'armée va assumer
pressé par la nécessité d'utiliser les
tactiques qu'elles dénonçaient il ya peu
chez ses adversaires mais en conservant
des garde-fous assure florence parly les
armées françaises ne déstabiliseront pas
un état étranger à travers des actions
informationnel qui viserait par exemple
ses processus électoraux les équipes de
cyberdéfense s'engageront en outre à
respecter le droit national et
international notamment la charte des
nations unies ainsi que les règles du
droit international humanitaire 1
milliard 600 millions d'euros sera
consacré à la cyber défense de la france
entre 2019 et 2025 l'armée souhaite des
recrues experte en langue rare encodage
en psychologie
le ministère va embaucher environ 800
cyber défenseur en plus des mille sont
déjà prévues à troller c'est un sport de
riches et c'est la fin de cette édition
se retrouve dans une trentaine de
minutes pour un nouveau journal à tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
le coeur des femmes est plus fragile que
celui des hommes en france c'est 200
femmes par jour qui décèdent de maladies
cardio cérébrovasculaires c'est à dire
ses choeurs cerveau artères et c'est une
véritable urgence épidémiologique parce
que c'est l'hygiène de vie qui a fait
celui des maladies cardiovasculaires des
femmes première cause de mortalité six
fois plus que le cancer du sein par
exemple il ya toujours trois fois plus
importante chez les hommes que chez les
femmes mais ce qui nous alertent nous
c'est la progression du nombre de femmes
jeu